hey we've got uh we got andy staples
joining the show
covers college football for the athletic
because he's going to help us make sense
of the news this week that the
the sec might just destroy college
football is that's what's happening here
andy if
if the big 12 is no more with texas and
oklahoma jumping ship
i mean does that destroy college
football i think they still continue
playing it
it'd still appear on my television so i
don't know if it destroys it it would
definitely be a little bit top heavier
uh because yeah i always laugh because
everybody says well they're going to go
to 416 team super conferences
listen if the sec adds texas and
oklahoma there's one super conference
and one kind of super conference with
the big ten
nobody else has any claim on the word
super after that
i do you know i do love the traditional
rivalries that we get in college
football regardless if they have
national championship implications do
you think this move from
texas and oklahoma that will not destroy
college football but destroy it as we
know it and we'll create something new
from the rubble and the ash from the
that's
like destroying traditional rivalry
like texas and texas a m whoever played
since 2012 who now would play again
no you're going to create new ones so i
was going to ask you with the sort of
college football
uh as we know it being something of the
past what do you think the benefits are
from a possible you know re-juggering
around of everything
i
there's a lot of words that are getting
sort of invented here because
we've not seen something like this in a
while i mean this happened
10 years ago this is very similar to the
way it happened 10 years ago but this
feels more extreme
because back then there weren't mega
brands moving
you know the biggest brands that move
were nebraska and texas a m
this is texas and oklahoma saying we're
not good with where we are
we would like to go over here because we
think that's where the better future is
but it will be different it will be more
topic the thing
the thing you would be concerned about
if you're
running college football which by the
way no one actually runs college
football it's
sort of a bunch of systems uh
it made all this money by going from
being a regional sport to being a
national sport
you add texas and oklahoma to the sec
the sec
suddenly has its own gravitational pull
it's its own plan
basically and really the big ten is the
only other league
that is is somewhat competitive there
and so you've
now concentrated most of the interest in
the sport in the south and the midwest
which
let's be honest those are the places
where people were most interested in the
sport before
but it was better as a national
proposition it was probably more
lucrative as a national proposition
the money's still going up but the
question is
is there a peak at some point because
now
if you're on the west coast if you're in
the northeast uh if you're in the upper
midwest
are you not as interested in in the
sport
because it doesn't feel like there's
anything for you that's something
that's a that's a 15 20 years from now
question
but if you're the sec right now and and
you know
when this happened in texas and oklahoma
knocked on your door and said
mind if we come in you have to say yes
you have to take them
i mean be crazy not to andy staples from
the athletic joins the show college
football senior writer and host of the
andy staples show
podcast what does this mean for
traditional powers who haven't
really seen themselves as a part of the
national championship
conversation in recent years schools
like miami usc
michigan tennessee i feel like you're
subliminally
you're sub tweeting rich here he's
throwing why just throwing in uh what's
a little shot at usc or just like uh you
know trying to get some michigan talk in
there
yeah i i don't know i i what does it
mean for them
it means basically the same you need to
be better than alabama
and and oklahoma and uh ohio state
and clemson if you'd like to win the
national title i mean that that doesn't
really change anything for them
the the teams that are competing for the
national title
it doesn't really matter what conference
they're in that's who they are
and you need to be better than them so i
think that that's
that's what it means for them now ufc is
a little bit different animal like
miami's in the acc the acc is pretty
stable
you've got you know clemson in there
you've got north carolina another big
brand not a huge football power but they
so that leak at the moment seems pretty
stable but like ufc
was not happy with the way the pac-12
was being run
they have changed commissioners in the
pac-12 so maybe maybe things have
have calmed down but if you're usc
you're looking at this and suddenly
feeling very isolated
if you're organ or washington you know
which is
similar to usc where good football
programs on the west coast with very
passionate fan bases
more passionate than most of the other
ones on the west coast you're looking at
that and going
we feel very alone out here so what do
we do
and and i don't i don't know what the
answer that question is
ben line's filling in for rich on the
rich eisen show joined by andy staples
from the athletic
um you mentioned that there was a shake
up about 10 years ago but 10 years ago
in college
football we didn't have name image and
likeness like we do today
uh we also didn't have the transfer
portal like we do today
how will those be impacted by uh this
move and change in the balance of power
well i just you
probably will have leagues if teams that
are in the sec and in the big ten
which which have the the biggest reach
and will continue to have the biggest
reach
they will have an advantage they will
have an advantage in terms of
you know look we have these big
passionate fan bases they're going to be
able to help you out
that these businesses are going to want
you promoting their products because
look at all the people you can reach
look how many fans we have
that's i mean that's real but i don't
know that's really any different than
than 10 or 11 years ago
what's different is the players now have
some basic economic rights
and can take advantage of that do you
think the
uh the changing of up of the current
system
uh will lead to a deeper playoff
structure are we going to have a 16
team playoff structure in the future you
think for college football
we're gonna have a twelve team playoffs
they've already said it they're they're
they're working their way through the
logistics of it now but it's it's going
to be 12
teams and the top four
ranked conference champs will get buys
uh the
the number five through nine seeds will
host home games in the first round
and the reason they did it this way is
because the the thought was okay
you can go to eight but there were a lot
of leagues that said well we don't want
it to be
just the best state or whoever you know
some group of people thinks is the best
date
we want conference championships to
matter and the sec looked at that and
said okay
fine if you want to have automatic bids
for conference champion
you can't make it where there are fewer
at-large bids than there are now because
right now the 14 playoffs
and there are four at-large bids
basically and so
the compromise was you go bigger to 12
and so there are now six at larges and
six spots guaranteed for conference
champs
and that helps the pac-12 which couldn't
get into the playoffs
that helps the big 12 which struggled to
get in the playoffs it helps those group
of five leagues that
never really had a real chance that at
least one of them is going to get in now
but it really helps the sec in the big
ten
where you could have two three
four shoot maybe five with this new sec
of your teams getting in andy staples
joins the show from the athletic
college football senior writer ben lions
filling in for rich on the rich eisen
show
as we look uh with a look ahead to
another college football season uh on
the horizon just as someone who covers
the sport someone who has a passion for
the game
where do you like to spend your
saturdays you could pick any stadium any
school any campus
to uh to spend a saturday afternoon in
the fall
well the the best tailgating on the
planet is lsu
uh and and i know you probably love your
school or you're some nfl fan who thinks
who thinks you guys know how to tailgate
you're wrong go to an lsu game
they will teach you everything you need
to know about
cooking an alligator over an open flame
or making gumbo for 100
in a pot that is you know being powered
by your
your rv uh there's one guy who has
this rv set up where they it's almost
like a
a fancy food truck where they they bring
the bar
down it's like a 20-foot bar and he's
got a daiquiri machine that's been
working since
1976 and still works today
these people are just miraculous and
then you get into the stadium
and it's loud and it's just incredible
so that that's the best
atmosphere for a football game that
you'll ever find but
i'm i'm old though i'm getting to the
point where
i would almost rather be at my house and
and see if i can borrow some tvs from
some neighbors
and get five tvs going and just watch
everything because
i that's that's a good saturday for me
where i could just go from
from noon eastern to whenever the hawaii
game ends
and and pass out got a couple names for
us here in july that we should keep tabs
on for heisman watch
sam howell at north carolina the
quarterback is is a really interesting
one
this is this is a guy who may be the the
first qb off the board in draft next
year
and you know it's weird because when he
was coming out of high school
we probably wouldn't have looked at him
as a potential
first-round draft pick quarterback just
because of measurables and all that
but now that we've seen baker mayfield
and kyle murray and those guys
you know you don't have to be the the
6'5 gunslinger
to to get that spot and sam howell is
really great
at operating an up-tempo offense he's
got a very good arm
so that that's when i watch i think he's
going to put up very big numbers
bryce young the new starting quarterback
at uh at alabama uh
very interesting what he does because
they lost quite a bit
in terms of firepower but they're
alabama they've always got the best
recruits so
he he'll have something he'll have guys
to throw to but you know
what what will he look like what will
they look like and then the guy
replacing trevor lawrence at clemson dj
uncle away he was really good in the two
games he started last year
but can he keep it up can you keep them
you know at a national title caliber
level
you know the coach of my football team
says he attacks every day with an
enthusiasm
unknown to mankind when asked if he eats
vitamins he says yes i have a steak
every single day so this is a man
who makes khaki pants look good i love
the michigan wolverines get me excited
for jim harbaugh in the upcoming season
do i have to try i'm
a little worried to be honest i mean you
think about that
jim harbaugh took a a pay cut they cut a
salary in half
basically michigan couldn't find someone
that was a slam dunk replacement so they
they cut a deal with harbaugh to make it
where it wasn't going to cost them any
more money if they fired him after this
season
or if they fired him after last season
so this is basically
last ditch will this work they've
changed their staff around
uh i'm curious to see what he does at
quarterback because they've got caden
k mcnamara there you'd think he he's the
the guy to come in
but then they've got a they've got a
true freshman
uh named j.j mccarthy who's a big time
recruit
will he get a shot uh they have a
transfer from from texas tech named alan
bowman who actually
played for chris kingsbury at texas tech
that's how old he is
uh who cliff king's ray loved but has
had some injury issues
and so i'm very curious to see who jim
harbaugh picks
to run that offense and are they any
different than they were last year
because
if they're anything like they were last
year this will be jim harbaugh's last
year
listen you're talking to a guy who has
promised drew henson and got four years
of john navarre so i'm very excited to
see who they have at quarterback uh as
well andy i appreciate you taking some
time man thank you so much
yeah thank you andy staples joining the
show not fired up for the maze in blue
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here